all right we are ready for another
doctor Sadler's philosophy pop up and
the topic that I decided to pick this
month to talk about is banning and
blocking on the online forums media
whatever you want to call them it's
something that I've been giving a lot of
thought to and occasionally having
discussions with with colleagues about
especially those who are you know as
tied in to the online world as I am so I
thought I would you know put out some of
my reflections and practices and you
know see what people thought of that and
discuss that today and I think that I
mean if the first thing I want to say is
is that generally I don't have too much
of a problem with with banning or
blocking people on YouTube Twitter
Facebook where else do I do it
occasionally on Google+
sometimes I'm linked in it tends to be
for different reasons and I'm sort of I
suppose if there's a spectrum where like
one end of the spectrum is every single
contribution that a person makes to the
marketplace of ideas is absolutely
important and you know unless it's
totally egregious in how you know how
bad or offensive it is we shouldn't ban
it or block it there or take any action
and then there would be like the other
end of the spectrum which would be like
hey if you cross any lines whatsoever
like if you use a swear word or ever
attack another user or something like
that will ban you and block you and and
do that and then there's everything in
between and actually I only know not
only do I have to do this in terms of my
own online presence but I also have to
do this to a certain degree
as editor of Stoicism today when we have
comments that become you know too
aggressive you know in civil you could
say and and and I also have to do it in
online forums believe it or not for my
academic online classes and usually what
I end up doing in cases like that for
classes or for stoicism today is I'll
say listen here's the comments policy
and you know you're starting to really
go over the line I'm gonna remove your
comment don't do it again and
occasionally I'll get people who are
fairly reasonable about that quite often
they double down and then they have to
be banned and I think this is actually a
very important topic because we do have
to deal with you know trolling of all
different sorts and it's not something
that is going to go away anytime soon
it's really part of the environment it's
been part of the online environment
since since it first came out and it's
it's not going to disappear so this is
something that I think philosophers need
to put some thought into and my my own
views and and practices on it are I
guess I'll just sort of lay them out and
we'll see what people make of it or what
they have to say about it cuz I'm
interested in you know thinking some of
these things through that I haven't
completely thought through I see people
are asking all sorts of questions that
are totally unrelated to the topic of
the the hangout for today so I'll get to
those in a while but I'm going to give
priority to questions and comments that
I actually have to do with the topic
this isn't just an AMA this is this is a
little bit more focused so what does it
take to to get banned or blocked it
really depends on the format and and so
let me say that LinkedIn is kind of an
outlier I do get a few people every once
in a while who get themselves banned or
blocked or I remove them as a connection
for the same reason that I would end
like YouTube or Facebook or Twitter but
it winds up usually being the fact that
they're trying to pitch me some sort of
service and they didn't do their due
diligence and so I think that's
something worth exploring what do I mean
by this
I get LinkedIn requests from people and
I generally say yes to LinkedIn requests
unless it's somebody who's clearly just
trying to grow their network they have
16 connections they you know they don't
know me from Adam and I don't know why I
should you know harness my my you know
thousand plus connections hurt for them
but you get a lot of people who think
that LinkedIn is a strategy for
essentially pitching things to other
people and I don't have a problem with
that per se what I do have a problem
with are people who are lazy people who
don't do their work when they're
pitching because if you're pitching me
with the kind of business that I have
and the interests that I have the same
sort of thing that you would be pitching
to I don't know some some management
executives somewhere you're clearly
doing the wrong sort of well you're not
even doing research you know you're just
sort of sending stuff out there into the
ether and hoping that it sticks and and
why does it bother me because it's
wasting my time and my time is valuable
and it you know on LinkedIn it's all
business stuff so if you're if you're
you know making a connection to me
you're definitely already you know
taking up a resource which is my time
right Facebook YouTube Twitter that it's
also the case there but it's not quite
so direct and so I I do in fact
occasionally ban and block people
usually I just remove them as a
connection and and drop them so let's
let's switch now to talking about the
the more let's call them more
personalized social media less less
straight business stuff where we're
hashing things out you know when people
get into arguments I actually created a
YouTube video just to deal with people
who seem to want to debate and so now if
some
being very contentious like if they
start out saying you know I put I'd post
something about something and then they
start sounding off about it you know I
think a lot of people assume that in the
online environment those of us who are
content creators or who are putting
things out there are sort of like there
for them and and we are in an abstract
sense but we're not there for them like
24/7 you know willing to hear them out
doing you know lots and lots of
engagement unless there's already a
relationship built up a relationship
that's based on some sort of mutual
respect and Trust I think other people
you know view it a different way some
people really love to debate and you
know so they've creates annals and and
Facebook pages and that's great for them
right or and if they have the time to do
that you know more power to them other
people you know have other reasons for
doing what they do I'm primarily about
putting content out there that I think
is going to be helpful for people and I
can't occasionally be be wrong about
something and when I am i generally
admit it but if I put a video out there
and I'm claiming that Aristotle said X Y
Z hell I've been reading and studying
Aristotle for I don't know what like 30
years now teaching at him for almost 20
so the odds of me actually getting it
mixed up are probably pretty low and you
know if somebody's got some tendentious
read you know because they they got into
somebody who doesn't like Aristotle or
they have a you know particular reading
of Aristotle like let's say they got
them through scholastic philosophy or
through Rand or something like that they
may be off base right and if they want
me to take the time to discuss the
matter with them then in my view they
have to follow certain basic rules of
engagement if you were to come up to
somebody on the street and just start
spouting stuff off to them imagine you
you came to to a lecture by an author
and you immediately got up and
you you know weird like ranting about
something they they wouldn't put up with
that very long I mean I usually find
some way to turn it turn the
conversation back to what we're actually
talking about but you know they're not
it's not incumbent upon them to answer
you it's not as if we have an automatic
right everybody has a right to express
themselves right but you don't have a
right
automatically to have somebody engage
you and and I see a lot of people who
insist on this and interestingly it's um
it's you know you'd say well that's
that's probably a male thing no it's
it's pretty equal opportunity it's more
of a jerk thing it's an entitled jerk
thing where people are like you have to
engage me because you put the content
out there and I think what they're
they're missing is you know when we
create a channel that's our channel no
it also belongs to YouTube but it's sort
of like going to somebody's studio or
classroom or house you're coming in as a
guest and if you act like a jerk you're
not going to be able to be a guest for
very long
I mean I've kicked people out you know
when I was younger and had guests who
were jerk I've kicked people out of my
house before or my or my mom's house
people who are in in school you know
with me and who I thought transgressed
certain lines you know and I'm pretty
tolerant when it comes to that sort of
stuff you get a couple chances but if
you screw up that's that you know and so
now one of the one of the I think side
topics of this and then I'll start
answering questions in just a minute is
you know banning and blocking it seems
like a rather permanent solution right
you you block somebody and then they
can't participate or not on YouTube it
doesn't mean they can't view your videos
it just means that they can't comment on
your videos on Facebook if you actually
block somebody it means that they can't
see your content right and so my page
has a quite a few people blocked who you
know we're acting like like jerks in one
way or another and who usually had
multiple chances on blogs again I think
it's usually comment you can't you can't
comment on something what about Twitter
if you Twitter really only allows you
you can mute people so you can't see
their stuff and they can rant at you all
they like or you can block them in which
case they can't see your tweets but they
can see that you have them block whereas
on Facebook
I think they can't even see that you're
blocked you just disappear from it I'm
not quite sure how it works in Google+
I've only blocked a few people in there
and I have blocked and unblocked a few
people from time to time but usually
when somebody gets blocked that that's
it for them so you could say well is is
that fair that that they you know
there's such a permanent solution to
things and you know my view is that yes
it is again because it's whoever is
creating the content whoever is managing
the channel or feed or whatever it's
it's there it's their place right and
there's nothing that actually prevents
somebody who's blocked in one medium
from reaching out in another medium like
email for example and saying hey I saw
that you blocked me I am you know I'd
like to have a conversation about this
I'm you know one of the things that made
me realize early on when I was still
living in Kingston and when I was just
really getting started in this YouTube
then Google+ business I blocked a guy
and he actually called me on the phone
and he was very very upset about the
fact that he'd gotten blocked and we had
a conversation and and I eventually
unblocked him but I only unblocked him
after he could like show me that he
understood where he'd you know crossed
lines and that he was actually sorry
about it because if somebody's just
gonna keep doing the same thing it's not
like you owe them
the opportunity to sit there and say
abusive things and it's not like you're
cutting them off from the whole internet
right it's very different with like for
example there's a case and I'm not sure
how it's been decided but you know
Donald Trump's Twitter feed he blocked a
number of people and it you know people
were legitimately saying and I think
this would be the case for any elected
official
they were legitimately saying listen if
you're putting the stuff out there and
it's part of public debate you don't
have the right to block people from
seeing what you're posting or cut them
off from commenting on what you're doing
but if you're if you're not in that sort
of environment you know and you're not
like say CEO of a major corporation or
something like that or some major media
figure I think it's perfectly fine for
for people to block other people because
they're not preventing them from
engaging in discussion elsewhere and
they're not totally cutting them off you
know from from other avenues of approach
if you're blocked on on Facebook well
try a mailing or Twitter or YouTube or
this or that so I think it's you know
it's quite interesting you know these
discussions and and I think a lot of
people put up with and I I did this for
a while they put up with a lot of time
wasting and tendentious arguments and
abuse that they don't they don't need to
because they feel like they're they're
under some sort of obligation to the the
people who are engaging with them I
almost said audience but it's not really
quite even at the level of an audience I
mean you do have your audience and those
are the people that keep coming back to
you over and over again and over time
you know I can tell you as a content
creator and as somebody who's engaged in
public philosophy you know you you
remember names and handles and stuff
like that and you you know you build up
a sort of virtual relay
with them sometimes it actually becomes
face to face I've met with lots of my
fans at conferences or various other
venues right and then the relationship
changes if they don't want to give you a
hard time maybe you'll put up with a lot
more but for some random person it's not
as if we owe them something just by
being out there now if you're on a
platform that's explicitly about public
engagement or debate or controversy or
something like that or if you create a
channel that's you know called something
like debate me bro you know and I think
you you probably don't have quite as
much cause to to say oh oh you're being
you know you're being rude you're being
mean you're wasting time with being
tendentious or something like that and
then you know the last thing that I'll
say before I start answering some
questions is somebody could say well who
the hell are you to say that somebody's
wasting your time
well I mean I'm in the same boat as you
can you tell if somebody else is wasting
your time you know time is the one
resource that we will never get back you
can lose a lot of money and make that
money back you can get out of shape and
get back into shape again although that
takes a lot of work you're never going
to get any of your time back so if you
waste it on you know arguments that are
really never going to go anywhere that's
a problem you can say how do you know
they're never gonna go anywhere you
haven't you know ventured fully into the
marketplace of ideas hey if I'm having a
conversation that looks like
conversations I've had 20 times already
and/or I've been doing for years and
years and years I am entitled just as
you are to decide this is probably going
to be a fruitless conversation so let's
go ahead and take a look so those are my
thoughts right kind of kind of rambling
there but let's take a look at some of
the questions I'll come back to some of
the ones that aren't really connected
well let's see what we've got in here
okay so Caitlin Farah ball would you say
someone pitching a radical ideas ground
for banning if it's belligerent there's
the key thing if you're doing it
belligerently sure if somebody wants to
ban you they can I mean if you want to
pitch a radical idea there's there's
many ways you can do it you know and if
you if you don't understand like how to
approach people who you imagine disagree
with you you can take classes on there's
books out there on that there's websites
it's called rhetoric you know or
communications it's and you know it's
not that difficult to do I think that if
this is another thing to prudentially if
you have an idea that you think other
people are going to have a hard time
with and you want to be taken seriously
by them and listened to you probably
ought to try to frame it in a way that's
not belligerent doesn't mean you have to
be like you know pushover anything but I
mean there's a huge gap between
belligerent and being you know a
pushover or not assertive I mean
assertive is in the middle you know
[Music]
alright let's see what else we got Rob
Rob Renton Rob rabbit says leaving
Facebook is one of the best decisions
I've made I've heard other people say
that as well I think that you can manage
your facebook consumption rationally so
that it doesn't aggravate the hell out
of you you know or suck you into rabbit
holes that are also major time sucks but
I don't have any problem with people
leaving social media as a matter of fact
there's gonna be an enforced migration
pretty soon I don't know if you guys
know about this from Google Plus Google
is closing down Google+ so those of us
who've been using it for years and years
some of them are like let's go to this
platform let's go to this platform I
don't know that any of that's actually
going to like keep those communities
that have been developing for a very
long time
around which is so it's kind of a loss
it's too bad but Google+ never took off
the way it was intended to in part
because Google didn't really support it
adequately
you know you can say with Facebook they
don't have a choice about whether they
support Facebook ethically that's their
main product right but Google+ is always
kind of a sideline all right let me see
here
Jessica bass the topic seems akin to
Jonna
Jonathan rocks kindly inquisitors I
wonder where route would stand on free
thought and talk now that the Internet
has become our prevalent interaction
sources thoughts well I haven't read
route so I can't say much about that I
mean it is that that raises a really
interesting topic though so you know
there's all these great media theorists
out there from the past who had quite a
bit to say about how interaction between
people through media changes things for
us and I would actually include in that
the classic three existentialist you
know fathers of existentialism certain
Kierkegaard read his present age you
know for an example Fyodor Dostoevsky
and Friedrich Nietzsche and maybe loves
chess talk to but then you've got people
are focusing specifically on media of
different sort like Walter on Marshall
McLuhan
I'd include Umberto Eco in there and now
echo saw the beginnings of the internet
but he didn't live to see how it how it
panned out you know in the present right
but yeah what would they make of the
fact that we are now so tapped in and
you know worldwide like you're seeing me
right now on a big iMac that has you
know camera but that's kind of a first
world thing worldwide much more people
are tapped in little mobile devices
usually phones sometimes tablets and
that makes a huge difference as well so
yeah I mean that's all I have to really
say about that
[Music]
srj then there are those who where
they've I've been blocked by so-and-so
badge with pride yeah there there are
quite a few people who do that that's
kind of interesting
now it could give you some currency in
certain areas right so you're you're you
know on the right and you you trumpet
the fact that you've been blocked by
these people on the left and see that's
a sign that they're not willing to do
honest bate and blah blah blah blah blah
but you acted like a jackass at the end
you right now they may have been a
little bit more prone to ban you because
of the political differences right and
we could pick anything else we want and
there happens from people on on the Left
who crow about how they've been banned
by people on the right happens with the
atheist verses you know religious people
thing happens in the splits and the
atheist community happens over you know
feminism and the whole transgender
community and you know the whole mannose
fear you know going back and forth with
each other
you could you could really and it
happens within communities as well where
we're for the most part they agree with
each other
but there's little splits and the
comedian right is it really something to
brag about having been banned does it
give you a kind of currency it certainly
can be a talking point but it doesn't
mean that you actually know anything it
just means that you've managed to
transgress enough social norms that that
people thought that they didn't want to
engage with you hate more so yeah that
that's quite true and Caitlyn follows up
saying that's kind of what I'm getting
at because they are a radical and
belligerent they were a troll they see
it as a merit okay well and I think
there are some people you could say who
are just committed to trolling as
trolling right the people who I would
say that that there's like the people
who are like pure trolls on the one hand
and it doesn't matter what ideology
they'll just pick and choose whatever
can tick somebody off and then there's
the more selective trolls who want to
own the you know usually the libs right
but it could be own the atheists own
so and so you know I guess honey is that
owning thing any owning of that sort is
usually a self owning as well and it's
too bad because you know adopting a
position like that that's really
something that I should look into I'm
sure there's some really good literature
out there on this already but adopting
the position of the troll it stands in
the way of personal development and
intellectual development and I mean the
irony is that a lot of the people who do
that sort of thing think that they're
very intellectually or morally advanced
and you know somehow the people that
they're they're attacking are less so
but that's not that's not my experience
dealing with them so yeah that's kind of
interesting
Rob Brad but we've we have too much
power put into giants like Google that
can lead public opinion wherever they
please I'd agree with you on that we we
are in a media environment where you
know we've got a lot of problems with it
write a book book production for trade
books is done by five big publishers and
then you know you could be a
self-published author but Amazon's your
main source of distribution for that and
then we have this you know huge social
media networks which have massive
effects on things I mean Instagram you
know because people love sunflowers so
much leads to people trampling sunflower
fields and destroying crops of people
who are trying to earn a living and and
and and yeah we get a lot of our
information and news now from a
relatively small amount of sources in
terms of platforms but a lot of voice is
coming coming in through those so yeah
we I mean if you think about the big
tech giant's what are they you know you
know you have ones like Microsoft that
are more oriented towards
you know the software itself and buying
up platforms and things like that but
clearly have a massive stake in things
you have Google which starts out as
essentially a tool in the internet and
then blossoms and grows into a lot of
things including their own operating
systems and you know cars and things
like that you have Apple as well
Facebook is another one that started out
as a platform and then grew into a
massive company LinkedIn and Twitter you
know they're in that that sphere but but
Twitter is terrible with pitching ads
LinkedIn is incredible with the
sophistication with which they they tell
you you know what you're you're you're
wanting to buy Yahoo was at one time a
contender but kind of blew everything
and are there any others Amazon of
course right and so you put all these
together and then start putting together
like the regional ones that you know for
like Russia or China or places like that
and a lot of power a lot of raw power
concentrated in just a few places let's
see what else we got in here oh here's a
good one
JJ and the anonymous online age what
other option is there to curate online
discussions other than banning or
blocking I mean yeah if you're dealing
with the anonymous things although you
know if you're on Facebook or YouTube or
Twitter or things like that it's it's
not really quite so anonymous right you
could send a message to the person
although I don't know that that doesn't
exist as an option anymore for YouTube
but you know I like in Facebook or
things like that you could send a
message to the person saying hey you got
a knock it off ur dial back on this sort
of thing but that that consumes time and
you have to ask is it is it really worth
it are you throwing good time after bad
so to speak do you owe it to them to do
that or should you just say listen you
want to act like a jerk get treated like
a jerk you know
yeah let's see what else we got here
okay encyclical what's the difference
between not allowing the president to
block people from his feed but allowing
corporations to block people from their
platforms seems rather one-sided yeah
you can make a good argument there that
that corporations shouldn't be able to
block people the argument of course is
going to be that you know we're talking
about a publicly elected position I mean
you might you might even go and say well
we make a distinction with public
officials between those who are elected
and responsible to an electorate and
those who are not like you know people
in who are appointees in in various
agencies maybe maybe they don't have to
be as receptive but I would say it's on
a continuum right I wouldn't say it's an
on/off switch although the courts will
probably handle it as a kind of on/off
switch I would say the heads of
corporations if they want to be out
there and they want to be using their
their Twitter feed or whatever for
promoting their business and talking
about policy then they lay themselves in
for carrying on discussions perfectly
fine for them to outsource it to
somebody else as a matter of fact Trump
would have done so much better I
realized that it's part of his strategy
but you know even even plenty of
Republicans are like this is way too
much you know somebody else should have
handled his Twitter feed a long time ago
but even if you do that it should still
still be publicly open maybe you know
along with that encyclical maybe the
presidents and chancellors of
universities if they have public feeds
maybe they shouldn't be allowed to block
people I mean they can always mute them
all right maybe they shouldn't be
allowed to as well because those are at
least certainly the state ones or public
trusts aren't they
private ones it gets a little bit a
little bit tougher yeah alright let's
see if we've got anything else in here
well we scroll scroll down a little bit
and then it jumped all over the place
okay here we go
so mr. guy 561 I'm fine with people
blocking others for spam accounts and
legitimate harassment but blocking for
having a different political opinion or
philosophical position on a topic is
problematic yeah I'm usually you know
like in my case people get blocked they
may in fact have a different political
opinion or philosophical position but
they've been a dick about how they
talked about it right and that's what
got them blocked it wasn't just having a
different opinion I mean here's who's
one of the things that often happens
right
somebody will chime in on something
it'll be some long rant and I'll say wow
that's a lot of verbiage about that
right and then they start firing stuff
off right sure reading all sorts of
things in you bla bla bla bla bla right
and I'm like didn't say that you know
and you if you ever see me saying good
luck with your studies that's my sort of
sign I left that's that's me saying I'm
not pursuing this conversation any
further and then a lot of times they
want to pursue it further and that's how
they get themselves blocked or banned so
that that's what happens quite often and
and it looks like nikki has a follow-up
are you talking about arguments for
against religion there I mean that would
fit into it really anything that's
controversial that could be a reason why
somebody would would block right and I
do think you shouldn't just block
because you find out that somebody's
opposed to what what values you hold but
if they act like a jerk and how they
they're going to talk about it that you
don't have to put up with that all right
all right principled uncertainty living
in Europe censorship is a painful topic
I'll uh I'll old quashing discussion but
somebody spamming your feed or
waxing has to be warns and then dealt
with yeah I noticed you're you're
willing to warn them if it's something
egregious I don't even bother with a
warning I just I just block them and
delete this stuff because there's sort
of a you know you could call it a
unwritten social contract if you're
gonna enter into discussion with other
people it has to be at least to some
degree civil and you can't get away with
saying well feel civil to me no you know
that's that's that's it we live in a
society with with other people who don't
automatically have to give us a pass and
yeah you know it's censorship is handled
differently in Europe I would say that
there you know at least with respect to
certain things there's more openness in
some countries but there's also some
things where no you just simply can't
talk about that I mean here in America
you can debate you know how bad the
Nazis were if you can even take the Nazi
side and things like that my you know I
knew people doing that when I was a kid
can't do that in Germany that's that's
simply off the what's out of the range
of possibility but you know you can
certainly go somewhere else and discuss
it right if you want to if you if you
feel the need to all right encyclical
what's the difference between trolling
and satirical journalism it's just an
updated version of satire for the
Internet age I don't buy that if you're
a journalist you're doing journalism
random trolling is you know it's not the
same thing as as journalism journalism
involves actually doing some research
and investigation and maybe editing a
bit and you know I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say that that that distinction is
eroded so that's some some troll just
randomly sounding off about stuff or or
saying the same thing that they happen
to have done you know a little bit of
research meaning like they looked at
Wikipedia somehow counts as journalist
you know well we should get it give all
the trolls we should issues and press
cards and let them into things I don't
think so I mean I don't even consider
myself a journalist right and I I do
something's in a live tweeting and stuff
like that but I don't I don't say I'm a
journalist because of that all right
microwave what do you think Marx would
have to say about the relationship
between content creators and YouTube he
would say it's exploitive I mean you
don't have to be Marx to say that
everybody says that YouTube giveth and
YouTube taketh away
all right you remember that ad pocalypse
awhile back when they changed the
algorithm algorithms and everybody was
up in arms because they've come to be so
dependent on making their money on
YouTube with you know makeup tutorials
or kittens or you know gaming stuff and
suddenly they were thrown into disarray
by that hey you know YouTube offers the
the framework and they definitely take
their cut and they you know I think part
of what really bothers people about
YouTube and about like you know talking
more broadly about Facebook or about
Google rankings for things is that the
processes are so untransparent and in
order to get insight into it you either
have to have insiders that you know or
you have to be you know very wealthy you
you already have to be so you already
got to be sort of like on the winning
side to derive stuff and you know from
the Marxist perspective Marx would say
yeah of course that's that's just how
capitalism tends to work now you know
what would be a solution to that I don't
know I haven't thought through very much
of that Caitlin and faribault can you
say a little bit more about Umberto eCos
vision you didn't really have a vision
as such he just he's a very important
contributor to understanding semiotics
and the philosophy of language and how
language interfaces with our entire you
know range of meaning so the internet is
it's not just one thing it offers a
number of different possibilities our
formats for new ways of conveying
information and cano ting denoting I
mean he covers a wide range of topics in
his books he's a systematic kind of kind
of guy I would actually start with his
theory of semiotics and start reading
that and you're gonna see all sorts of
really cool connections come up
principled uncertainty no opinion is too
hot to handle debates driven off the
public square go toxic I would say some
of those debates are already toxic and
and they're they're fine with being
driven off of the public square I'll
accept that they don't their egos get
bruised you know but many of them are
already toxic and I don't think that we
have to admit every single thing in
whatever the public square happens to be
and I'll tell you you know going back to
the original topic no one single content
producers platform or channel is the
public square so I think it's perfectly
fine for it you know individual channels
or even even large institutional things
to say here's the limits we're not going
beyond this you know and do they have to
like do it all in advance no it could be
done you know on a case-by-case basis it
can be done with general policies I
think all that is is quite alright but
you know you want to have a least some
possibility of transparency some
possibility of if there's an honest
mistake getting some really dress for it
yeah okay let's see what else we got
here mmm TK imagine if the government
had to provide people with a Social
Security sort of social media if social
media becomes a hue
right in the future so what are we
imagining there something like I guess
you know some sort of social media
network that the government itself would
provide and then like anybody could put
whatever they wanted on it yeah it'd be
interesting would it wouldn't it
actually function well or would it like
always be 30 steps behind their major
competitors and then I'll you know what
sort of headaches that the government
itself get into you know they'd have to
like figure out what can be allowed and
what can't be allowed and and then it
would change like every you know
election sequence you know new
administration comes in this is now okay
this is not okay I had to be interesting
wouldn't it all right let's see what we
got here
oh here's a great question from
betterment project what do I think about
the difference between a philosophy and
what movements it produces in the public
which those who are academics of the
philosophy only say well that's not what
it is I mean we'd have to think of some
examples of that are we talking about
like say Nietzsche where you know people
read Nietzsche and get excited and
they're like yeah you know I'm gonna be
part I'm gonna be part of the ubermensch
I'm gonna be part of the master race or
something like that and then you're like
well you know
Nietzsche actually said all these other
things instead I guess that that could
be part of it or you could say you know
with Marxism right but where where does
this really come up all that often where
philosophers are being used as the
pretext for this sort of stuff I mean we
can think of lots of historical
situations like Aristotle being
harnessed sort of against himself to
justify Antebellum slavery enslaving
Africans in in the United States or
Native Americans in South America
but and we do have you know I guess we
do have the thing where like people are
picking up on classical philosophy and
deforming it in the name of Western
civilization by you know the people who
have no clue what Western civilization
actually is let alone how it would
possibly be defended and we have plenty
of people on the on the left by the way
picking up you know whatever in an
eclectic way whatever they like from
whoever and turning it into quotes and
using it for justifications you know I
mean and we could go on and on about
this what do I think about that well I
think that it's kind of inevitable
you're not gonna really you can't police
people and say oh you must not talk
about Marx this way or you must not talk
about Aristotle this way what good is a
cadet I mean you can write an op-ed
piece if you want the the clue is there
that the key is not to like come down
from the top and and just like you know
impose a lot of rules the key is to like
engage with those audiences and offer
better stuff I mean it's amazing that
YouTube is here and if people want to
actually get the straight dope on
Aristotle or Ansem or Hegel they can't
they got to do a little bit of work to
do it right
get past the 5-minute glitzy high
production low low you know intellectual
content videos but that's not hard to do
right if you want to find people who
actually know their their business about
Aristotle online and can talk to a
contemporary you know general audience
it's there well that's where we ought to
be concentrating our I say our forces
and and our thought most academic
philosophers totally unsuited for that
some of them think that they're good at
that and then you watch them and you're
like well not very good but there's
quite a few more that that could be
doing it that would be good at it and we
don't encourage it at all
all right mr. guy it's natural for
people to avoid information that
challenges their belief system banning
facilitates this way too easily before
the internet people had to defend their
beliefs with others I mean let's be
honest about before the internet people
lived in just as many silos before the
Internet's as they do now in the age of
the internet I mean just read through
the social science literature from
before the internet and you'll see
people worried about that sort of thing
you know now banning facilitates that
that way too easily so what we should we
should remove banning we should just let
people troll as much as they like you
know that is that is that going to be
helpful or should we like maybe we have
to have a commission to review you
banning I mean we can say that that
banning may not be haven't allowing
people to ban may not be the best option
in many cases but I don't see a better
one yet anything that we propose to like
try to fix it seems more problematic
than the original practice doesn't it
let's see Rab rabbit a lot of time
trolling is building your argument by
throwing an extreme out there and
receiving the feedback I'll just take
your word for that I don't know too many
trolls because I don't I don't
people who troll I don't want to hang
out with them you know and I'm not
interested in interacting with them if
that's what it takes to like build your
argument is to like be a dick to people
I know plenty of other good ways to
build arguments so I you know it could
be that that 90% of the trolls out there
are honestly motivated with you know
trying to build the best argument
possible that doesn't seem like the case
to me but who knows betterment project
example would be deconstruction and
post-modernism and academics and in
public these are very different things
or when the people critique the public
version there's always academics who say
oh you don't understand
and they're right about that I mean
people who talk about deconstruction and
post-modernism and haven't actually
studied this stuff should shut the hell
up you know same thing with like
cultural Marxism Jesus every time I hear
somebody talk about that my it's like my
ears just you know sort of closed over
and I'm like well this is a waste of
time listening to this person and and
likewise a lot of critiques from the
left of you know authors on the right
Aristotle's just about you know
enforcing slavery well there's a dummy I
guess I don't need to listen to this
person anymore at least on this topic
because they're gonna be a waste of my
time you know you know we here's the
thing if you want to if you want to like
talk in jargon about stuff you got to
know what the jargon actually means and
what its source is doesn't mean you have
to be able to like write a dissertation
on it but you have to have done more
than just like you know Wikipedia it or
listen to some YouTube videos I have
zero sympathy with the people who liked
jabber on about deconstruction
post-modernism how dare you I ruin
things and you know haven't haven't
looked into any of this stuff I don't
see any point in listening to them and
I'm a pretty middle-of-the-road kind of
guy so you know those are those are
great ways to lose the few allies that
you might have in the world of ideas
doing that sort of thing so yeah let's
see what else we've got a lot more other
stuff here all right a lot of back and
forth between commentaries here too
Michael Pisco Reno is a sophomore in
college time is big every minute is
valuable and you're right and that you
can't get it back once it's used up
wasted I'm glad that you're
understanding that it's a sophomore in
college it took me a lot longer to learn
that myself you know I had to I
oftentimes I have to learn things
through experience that that I should be
able to learn through
you know reading other people's
reflections on things but yeah that's
that's true time is an important
resource Kanaga levy I wonder if there
could be an antitrust case against the
companies at censored info Awards they
all compete in the business of
propagating news and it seems like they
colluded a crush enforce demonstrate
collusion and then you've got a start
but if you can't demonstrate it then
you're just doing conspiracy theories
which is what Infowars was really so so
good at right and then you're kind of
you know you're showing that maybe
Infowars and the approach that it had
was kind of crap you know and you know
if you can show collusion good go ahead
and go ahead and do that all right
now King Ali wait YouTube makes - and
Google pays for it how do they exploit
you I'm not sure what you're you're
saying there but I mean that's something
you can do some research on you for the
amount of work that that content
producers do they're not seeing very
great rewards so take a look at that and
cyclical I probably should have used the
word pulenta sysm instead of satirical
journalism but I feel the point still
stands also they're doing they're being
polemical like say Schopenhauer or
Nietzsche most trolls are not really you
know intellectual brilliant stars or
something like that as a matter of fact
I really love this NPC
meme that's circulating around because
it brings so many things together you're
just parroting you know somebody else's
stuff
I don't care where you're coming from
you really are kind of an npc right
you're not you know you're not making
any sort of agency contribution of your
own to discussion and that's what I
think a lot of trolls basically do you
know so you can call it Palomas ism I
don't know I mean I I think you know
sure there's polemical stuff that's
really like down in the dirt but again
you know there's some great stuff out
there
you know I mean let's take somebody
who's a great polemicist eight Menken
who sometimes you cringe when you read
some of the stuff that he writes today
but he's really good at what he does
and it is kind of you know kind of an
interesting guy really that's what
that's what trolls are all doing III
just don't buy it
Martin Christian has a tendency us
argument here if your Twitter account is
like your house and the president should
not be allowed to ban people in
astroturf account then the president
can't kick people out of the White House
except that the Twitter account isn't
like your house I said it's like you
know your your porch it could be like
your house but it could also be like
your studio or things like that and you
can kick people out of out of places
like that and people can be kicked out
of the White House for all sorts of
other reasons like I don't know security
or convenience or things like that right
but you know you can make that argument
do a video on it or something like that
an order to hold do you think blocking
people blurs morality like confusing
being bothered by what is unjust maybe
for some people I think the more that
you you you know work in ethics and
train yourself with ethics probably the
less likely that's gonna be the case
I'm sure some people yeah a ban and
block all the time for all sorts of
stupid reasons or unjust reasons but I
think again blocking I think is actually
quite just let's see here Nicki Michele
T's seems a lot of the troll pages do is
make a joke that centers around X being
true and it's not overtime of jokes or
satire it seems to convince people
pretty fast can sanitaire be a weapon
all over the map there can santeri be a
weapon yeah I mean helps that helped
topple the the regime of louis xiv
didn't it and and you know yeah
sanitaire can can of course always be
some sort of weapon may be a blunt force
an ineffective weapon sometimes
sometimes it can be very
all directed also take care your your
word on what what troll' pages do you
know I try to spend as little time with
trolls as possible quite frankly because
again you know got out of your
priorities but yeah people people do get
convinced but people get convinced of
stupid things all the time you know this
is not a exception to the rule the level
of public discourse in the United States
it's pretty low it has been well my
entire lifetime now that means that you
can like you know raise raise it up but
all right let's see encyclical VA Shiva
is suggested using a post office
provided email address video uploading
page and blog page ok so the post office
is going to have all the the servers
required for maintaining that entire
network videos a lot of data right and
then if people are interacting back and
forth yeah that's gonna be a lot of data
to store as well but it's feasible you
know maybe that would even be a good use
of tax money I mean it needs to be
there's all sorts of liability issues
there you need to explore but you know
that's good
TK people being sent to government-run
social media etiquette courses to get
back after transgressions well that's
interesting I didn't know about that
that could be good I guess depends on
the courses I mean I've taken some
courses through the NIH and I have to
take like all these courses because I
have an academic teacher I'm like you
know slips and falls or title night and
all that and they're almost invariably
terrible I don't think they promote a
lot of learning and they you know let
alone like actual attitude or behavior
change but you know they could be a
start
let's see here Richard Elliot my pastor
block he's not Twitter which yeah
you know when you've got people that
you're close to that that can be a real
issue isn't it interesting now is a bit
of a digression how like you know you
you almost feel hostage in many respects
you got to keep this person as a contact
can't you know block this person even
though you're like I or you can't even
is like decouple from them unfriend or
no longer follow because you're supposed
to stay connected with people I used to
I used to you know worry about that now
I just you know if I don't if I don't
want to follow somebody I just you know
unfollow them or unfriend them if I
think you know they're not good good use
of my time every once in a while I go
through my LinkedIn contacts and I'm
like yeah I can prune some of these away
YouTube one of the because I follow so
many channels and I've just clicked
every once in a while a variety of them
including many who I disagree with but I
wanted to sort of keep tabs on when I
had the intention of actually doing that
dad I haven't gone through and prune for
a long time but I probably should you
know alright well that's the betterment
project yeah interaction seems to be the
right move ethics of virtue and
discussion perhaps interaction is the
right move when it's the right move you
know if you're talking virtue ethics
they're not going to say
across-the-board well you should always
interact with the troll you know it
would really depend on the right time
right person right reasons you know is
there really a possibility of having a
productive conversation or not yeah all
right getting close to the end for today
so let me see if we've got any others
[Music]
I don't even know what Rob rabbit is
saying here the NPC mean is false-flag
NPC mean that's just - it's like a bunch
of stuff they're there and you can like
a meme without endorsing everything
about it and everything people are doing
about it what I like about it is that it
captures the fact that it captures a
social phenomenon that has been going on
from before the internet meaning that
there's lots of people who just
endlessly chatter and don't have any
original thoughts of their own and I
don't mean an original I'm like
groundbreaking or anything like that but
they're basically just repeating
whatever they are programmed to do and
very often that includes stuff like I am
an original thinker I am a free thinker
stuff like that it's a great it's a
great idea it makes so many things fall
into place when you think about that and
I say that it is somebody who you know
encountered NPCs back as a kid playing
D&D right so all right I'll see if we
got any anything well here's a good one
Richard Elliott the third you got a
nasty troll a few years ago creepy
bastard you dealt with it quick fast
inspired confidence and me not sure who
it would be because I've had a lot of
nasty trolls so for theatres right and
and yeah I deal with them pretty quick
because they're not worth spending much
of my time on you know there's sort of
you know people sort of build up a sort
of a hierarchy I would say based on I'm
kind of like trust and you're worth you
know worth spending the time reading the
comments on an trolls are at the very
bottom it's one o'clock let me see if I
can I take a few others Rob Robert said
what I meant is the people that the NPC
mean was immediately over years then
adopted by the NPC yeah probably the
case right you know you know that's the
thing about memes you don't control them
Lucas as there's a coincidence I got
common banned for trolling Marg Vic
earnest black metal legend and murderer
now neo-nazi prepper not even two hours
ago can't say I feel guilty yeah I'm
sure I probably had a lot of people who
I I've been banned and blocked by but I
don't even bother to check myself and
then let's see Cobain how do you feel
about aggressively D platforming bad
actors that are trying to obfuscate
discourse people that consciously spread
lies or misinformation that damage
fruitful discussion so deep platforming
is a bit different than just like
blocking right because there you're
you're trying to agitate to get a
platform itself to remove somebody
there's you know and it only works if
you can a get a lot of other people
involved and be if the platform cares
enough about public opinion
how do I feel about it I you know I I
see some some some worries because we
and it's mainly because we do have just
a few big platforms but yeah III don't
see it as is entirely illegitimate and
then alright turns vying so what about
the language cultural barrier around the
internet I mean you can have people who
who are from a culture I guess who are
much more aggressive but that's tough
for them you know I mean if they're
gonna interact with with people on a
worldwide network figure out the mores
you know alright let's see about this
this is trolling thing Linden Bailey
Socrates is kind of trolling the whole
of Athens a higher form of trolling no
let's not let's not try to make trolling
into something that it's not
alright let's recognize it as the low
level generally not very intellectually
committed having fun at somebody else's
expense thing that it is let's not try
to pretend that it was it was you know
somehow serving some greater cause or
something like that so yeah there's some
discussion back and forth about that
and yeah I mean Simon Socrates it wasn't
wasn't just trying to screw with people
there was a point to it
he was ironic quite a bit at the time
and noticed you know I'll lend actually
I'm done this if you want to see the
sort of mixed attitudes towards irony
read Aristotle and read Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics he actually
criticizes Socrates for for his ironic
self deprecation and it's interesting to
note that right because Aristotle is
just two generations removed from him
and studying you know in the Socratic
lineage but yeah that's that's that's
his view all right so I'm gonna wrap
this up I got to do unfortunately a lot
of course development and grading and
stuff like that today the course
development I don't mind doing the
grading is the bane of professor's so
thanks for all the great questions and
comments I didn't get to a lot of the
the ones that are sort of off topic but
we'll have our a am a you know coming up
in in November I don't know if I I think
I've set a date for that you can find
out my Facebook page and you should be
also in the reason I you know calendar
so if you've got you know other
questions about other things go ahead
and bring them up then and oh yeah bish
beta yeah very nice ordered whole thank
you one day maybe an AI will grade
papers for you what well maybe but I
don't know if they'll do it well that's
the problem so and and and it's
important actually for me to see what
the students are understanding and not
understanding so I do complain about it
but I probably should alright I'll see
you some other time and I will have
another one of these on Facebook coming
up later on this month same topic and so
will be will be doing these pop-ups Oh
Lucas says is there a set schedule for
these pop-ups no that's the point their
pop-ups my patreon supporters find out
in advance at the beginning of the month
everybody else finds out the day of the
pop-up that's because their pop-ups
alright so on that I'm gonna leave all
of you have a great rest of the weekend
and I'll see you in the ether